مساء الخير،
هذا المساء، سوف أحدثكم عن المستشرق الفرنسي لوي ماسينيون،
الذي ولد في ضواحي باريس على ضفاف نهر المارن سنة 1883،
وتوفي سنة 1962 بمدينة باريس،
تاركا انتاجا معرفيا غزير،
حوالي 200 كتاب ومقالة،
و100 تقرير وشهادة،
و150 محاضرة باللغة العربية،
وهي المحاضرات التي ألقاها على طلابه في الجامعة المصرية،
والاف الرسائل بعضها لم ير النور بعد.
إلى جانب لغته الأم،
أتقن هذا المفكر الموسوعي العربية والتركية والفارسية والألمانية والإنكليزية.
عاش لوي ماسينيون بين عالمين،
فهو المسلم داخل المسيحيين والمسيحي داخل المسلمين.
يقول متحدثا عن رحلته الفكرية نحو الشرق العربي الإسلامي؛
«جذبني الشرق إليه بماضيه الحافل بالديانات،
فإذا أنا غارق فيه إلى قمة رأسي،
وإذا فلاسفة الإسلام ومتصوفوه يحظون جميعاً بالقسط الأكبر من تفكيري،
وإذا أنا بعد دراستي إياهم أنجذب نحو المنبع الأول،
الذي استقى منه هؤلاء الفلاسفة تصوفهم وفلسفتهم».
اهتم لوي ماسينيون في دراساته الإسلامية بشخصيات اشكالية،
شخصيات قلقة، تقع في مفترق الهويات ويصعب القبض عليها،
البداية كانت مع شخصية الحسن الوزّان،
المعروف بليون الإفريقي،
وهو رحالة اندلسي ولد في غرناطة سنة 1483،
أي قبل سقوطها بحوالي عشر سنوات،
هُجّرت عائلته واستقرت بمدينة فاس المغربية حيث تعلّم بجامع القرويين،
كلفه سلطان فاس بعدّة مهام دبلوماسية،
مكنته من الترحال واكتشاف عدة أمصار في افريقيا وفي آسيا.
سنة 1520 اختطفه قراصنة القديس يوحنا،
في المياه المتاخمة لجزيرة جربة التونسية،
وقُدّم كهدية للبابا ليون العاشر الشغوف بالمعرفة والعلم،
فحرره وأشرف بنفسه على مراسم تعميده،
ومنحه اسمه وأصبح يعرف منذ ذلك الحين بيوحنّا ليون الإفريقي،
خلال إقامته قي القصر البابوي،
ألّف الحسن الوزان كتابا هاما عنوانه "وصف افريقيا"،
ويعرّف في مقدمته نفسه كالآتي:
" أنا الحسن بن محمد الوزّان،
يحنّى الدومتشي،
وأُدعى ليون الإفريقي،
ولكني لست من إفريقيا،
ولا من بلاد أوروبا،
ولا من بلاد العرب.
وأُعرَف أيضاً بالغرناطي والفاسي والزياتي،
أنا ابن السبيل، وطني هو القافلة، وحياتي هي أقلّ الرحلات توقعاً".
اختلفت الروايات حول مصير الحسن الوزان بعد وفاة البابا،
مما زاد في الملامح الأسطورية لهذه الشخصية،
البعض يقول انه انهى حياته مسيحيا في إيطاليا،
والبعض الآخر يقول انه عاد إلى تونس ليستعيد إسلامه وهويته.
انصحكم بالإطلاع على رواية الأديب اللبناني أمين معلوف،
"ليون الإفريقي"، لفهم الهوية المركّبة لهذه الشخصية.
ماسينيون سوف يقتفي أثار هذه الشخصية التي عاشت بين عالمين،
وسوف يسافر إلى المغرب لإعداد بحث دراسات عليا،
في إطار أطروحته حول ليون الإفريقي،
وفي الصحراء المغربية تعرضت قافلته للسطو،
وتآمر عليه دليله العربي الذي تحدث بالعربية مع اللصوص،
دون أن يفهم ماسينيون ما دار بينهم،
ومنذ ذلك الحين قرر تعلم هذه اللغة وإتقانها.
بعد هذه الرحلة سوف ينشر كتابا حمل عنوان؛
"اللوحات الجغرافية في بلاد المغرب في الخمسة عشر عاما الأولى من القرن الثامن عشر طبقا لليون الأفريقي".
سنة 1906، تحصل لوي ماسينيون على دبلوم لغة عربية في باريس.
ودبلوم آخر في اللغة العربية المحكية من مدرسة اللغات الشرقية.
ثم تابع دروسه في جامع الأزهر في القاهرة،
وتعرف هناك على المستشرق الألماني الشهير غولد تسيهر،
وارتدى مثله الزي الأزهري.
سنة 1907، كُلف لوي ماسينيون بالقيام بمهمة تنقيب عن الآثار،
وبالتحديد عن قصر "الأخيضر" جنوبي كربلاء.
وفي أيار سنة 1908، اشتبه في أمره ضابط تركي يدعى حازم بيك،
فألقى عليه القبض، ووُجهت له تهمة التجسس،
والاشتراك بالمؤامرة الماسونية ضد السلطان عبد الحميد،
وحُكم عليه بالإعدام.
اُقتيد عبر سفينة في نهر دجلة إلى بغداد،
وعند مروره بطاق كسرى،
رأى من نافذة قُمرته الصغيرة حمامة تهدل فوق شجرة نخيل،
هذه الحمامة سوف تكون مصدر تجربة إشراق روحي لماسينيون،
يستحضر من خلالها شهيد الحب الإلهي الحسين بن منصور الحلاج،
الذي سوف يكون سنده في هذه اللحظة الفارقة في حياته،
يقول في كتابه "الوعد" متحدثا عن هذه الرؤيا الروحية؛
"رأيت ناراً داخلية تحاكمني وتحرق قلبي،
وكأنني أمام حضور إلهي لا يمكن التعبير عنه،
حضور خلاق يوقف إدانتي بصلوات أشخاص غير مرئيين،
زوارٍ لسجني، التمعت أسماؤهم فجأة في مخيلتي،
ولأول مرة أصبح قادراً على الصلاة وكانت تلك الصلاة باللغة العربية."
ماسينيون سوف يصلي في حضرة الحلاج صلاته الكاثوليكية باللغة العربية.
استمعوا إلي شهادته حول هذه اللحظة المصيرية؛
هذا النداء للحلاج،
الذي هتف في تلك اللحظة في قلبي،
استحثّني للذهاب إلى بغداد،
اين مات، أردت إعادة تركيب إطار نشوة آلامهه،
رغم ان الأمر حدث منذ 1000 عام،
وفي 1906 وضعت هذا التصوّر،
ومن باب الصدف،
لأنني لم أحدث أحدا في الأمر، الأشياء العميقة لا نحدث بها أحدا،
عُرض عليّ القيام بمهمة في بغداد،
كنت وقتئذ عضو في المعهد الاركيولوحي بالقاهرة.
لم يسبق لنا أن قمنا باي مهمة في بلاد الرافدين،
وعُرضت عليّ واحدة،
وشعرت في تلك اللحظة، شعرت أنني محمول بقدري،
ليس لأنني أؤمن بشيء، لم أكن اعتقد في الاه،
لكنني حُملت في حركة مثل السفينة التي ترفع مراسيها لتشجّ البحر،
رفعت المرساة دون أن أكون راغبا في ذلك،
صعدنا عبر نهر دجلة في اتجاه بغداد، بعد 23 يوما في سفينة شحن إنجليزية صغيرة،
كنت بمعية حجيج ذاهبون إلى كربلاء،
كانوا حجيجا فرس،
هم كذلك ذاهبون للحج عند  مقام  ميّت وأنا كذلك ذاهب للحج عند  مقام  هذا المصلوب من أجل الحب الاهي،
وعند المرور أمام طاق كسرى،
الذي عرفته، وقد فقد في تلك السنة  نصف واجهته،
وجدت في المكان الذي أُسر فيه الصليب،
وتم تحريره  من طرف هرقل قبل الإسلام،
في ذلك المكان بعد ستة أشهر أجد نفسي بين يدي الله،
أدركت الحلاج،
أدركت ذلك النداء الذي بعث به لي الحلاج،
وفي وحدة روحي،
استجرت به،
ومن الأسماء، في تلك اللحظة امام الله، التي سمحت لي أن أنجو من خطاياي وذنوبي،
كان، وأحسست بذلك مباشرة في قلبي، اسم هذا الرجل،
الذي مات منذ الف عام مضت،
مسلم محل جدل وموسوما بالزندقة.
بتدخل من الأديب والمؤرخ العراقي  محمود شكري الآلوسي وشقيقه القاضي علي نعمان الآلوسي،
سوف يتم إطلاق سراح لوي ماسينيون.
بيت الآلوسي سوف يكون نافذة لوي ماسينيون على الشرق،
وعلى الحضارة العربية الإسلامية،
ماسينيون سوف يكتشف الضيافة العربية عند آل الآلوسي،
وسوف تصبح الضيافة مفهوما مركزيا في فكره،
في رسالته إلى الأب الكرملي بتاريخ 25 تموز سنة 1914 كتب ماسينيون؛
" لا أخبار لدي عن شكري أفندي ولا الحاج علي وهذا يحزنني،
قل لهما اني احبهما كثيرا واذكرهما امام الله لعظمة الطيبة التي منحوني اياها،
والثقة التي غمروني بها، انا الضيف الغريب".
هذه الرسالة سوف تحملنا إلى نافذته الثانية على الشرق،
وهي الراهب العراقي انستاس ماري الكرملي،
وهو شخصية عروبية مسيحية هامة سوف تعاني من سخط الباب العالي،
الكرملي كرس حياته لخدمة اللغة العربية،
أسس مجلتي لغة العرب ودار السلام،
وله عدة مؤلفات من اهمها،
نشوء اللغة العربية واكتِهالها والفوز بالمراد في تاريخ بغداد.
وفي هذا الإطار احيلكم على كتاب هام جدا،
للكاتب العراقي علي بدر،
يحمل عنوان،
ماسينيون في بغداد، من الإهتداء الصوفي إلى الهداية الكولونيالية،
وجمّع فيه علي بدر ولأول مرّة رسائل ماسينيون التي بعث بها للأب انستاس ماري الكرملي.
سنة 1912 سوف تنتدب الجامعة الجامعة المصرية لوي ماسينيون أستاذاً زائرا لتدريس تاريخ الفلسفة،
وألقى بالعربية عشرات المحاضرات،
حول «التكوين التاريخي للاصطلاحات الفلسفية»،
وكان من بين تلاميذه طه حسين.
مع اندلاع الحرب العالمية الأولى سنة 1914،
سوف نكتشف وجها آخر من وجوه لوي ماسينيون وهو أكثر وجوهه اشكالية،
حيث تم تعيينه  مستشاراً في وزارة المستعمرات الفرنسية في شؤون شمال إفريقيا.
وشغل خطة مستشار سياسي لبيكو(الطرف الفرنسي من اتفاق سايكس/بيكو )،
وكان في الجانب المقابل لورنس العرب،
مستشارا سياسيا لسايكس الطرف الإنجليزي،
من الاتفاق الاستعماري بين فرنسا وبريطانيا.
وكذلك شغل ماسينيون منصب مستشار للمندوب السامي الفرنسي،
في سورية وفلسطين من سنة 1917 إلى  سنة 1919.
وهو كذلك من مهندسي اتفاق فيصل وجورج كليمنصو،
الذي نص على قبول المملكة السورية بالانتداب الفرنسي.
بعد سقوط حكومة جورج كليمنصو في فرنسا،
سوف ينسحب لوي ماسينيون من الوظائف السياسة،
وفي جرابه عدة خيبات،
منها اعتقاده ان فلسطين سوف تكون،
نموذجا للإخاء والمحبة بين أبناء ابراهيم اليهود والمسيحيين والمسلمين.
بعد ذلك سوف يكون من أشد المعارضين للمشروع الصهيوني،
وقيام دولة إسرائيل وتقسيم فلسطين.
صحيح ان لوي ماسينيون،
المستشرق الكاثوليكي ذهب إلى الشرق مبشّرا بالمسيحية،
وحاول أحيانا التوفيق بين تعاليم الكتاب المقدّس و الخارطة الإستعمارية،
ولكنه عاد إلى الغرب مبشّرا بإسلام آخر،
وجد فيه عقيدته المسيحية.
فعلى عكس مواطنه المستشرق أرنست رينان،
الذي وضع الإسلام خارج القداسة في كتابه "محمد وأصول العقيدة الإسلامية"،
واعتبره غريبا عن اليهودية والمسيحية،
سوف يعمل لوي ماسينيون على البحث عن الجذع الإبراهيمي المشترك،
بين الإسلام و اليهودية والمسيحية.
ماسينيون سوف يبحث عن ذاته المسيحية في الإسلام،
سوف يحاول البحث عن أسرار هذا الإسلام،
الذي وُلد غاضبا من رحم اليهودية والمسيحية،
والذي كُتب على حد تعبيره بدموع هاجر التي ظلمها الوعد الإلهي،
ماسينيون سوف يبحث عن مريم العذراء في فاطمة،
وسوف يجد ذاته في سلمان الفارسي،
الشاهد المسيحي الأول على الإسلام والشخصية المحورية في نشأة التشيع،
وسوف يبحث عن الخيط الناظم،
بين أسطورة النيام السبعة في التراث المسيحي،
وقصة أصحاب الكهف في النص القرآني.
لكن الاهم،
هو أنه، سوف يجد،
في آلام الحسين بن منصور الحلاج وهو يصلب،
آلام المسيح،
فكما طلب المسيح المغفرة لقاتليه عندما قال؛
"يا أبت اغفر لهم، لأنّهم لا يعلمون ما يفعلون".
كذلك  طلب الحلاج المغفرة لقاتليه عندما قال؛
«قد اجتمعوا لقتلي تعصّبًا لدينك، وتقرّبًا إليك، فاغفر لهم،
فإنّك لو كشفتَ لهم ما كشفتَ لي لَما فعلوا ما فعلوا».
استمعوا إلى لوى ماسينيون،
وهو  يتحدث عن هذا التداخل بين بعض هذه الشخصيات التخومية،
في الإسلام والمسيحية.
اشكالية النيام السبعة التي تثير سخرية احد زملائي في الكولاج دي فرانس،
و يتساءل كيف آخذ على محمل الجد هذه الاسطورة،
التي آمنت بها كل المسيحية القديمة من الحبشة إلى سيبيريا،
وهي اليوم ليتورجيا الإسلام كل يوم جمعة،
وهو شيء فريد،
هذا الفصل من النيام السبعة مرتبط بشكل عجيب بالحلاج بالرقم 309،
ومرتبط كذلك وهو امر عجيب بفاطمة،
لأنه رقم مرتبط بالخلافة الفاطمية،
الفاطميون احتفلوا بخروجهم من سرداب الظلم الجور في المهدية في تونس،
عندما أسسوا عاصمتهم،
سنة 309 هجرية احتفلوا بالمهدية، أين كانوا فيها منذ سنوات.
هنا توجد ظاهرة غريبة لا توجد الا في الإسلام،
وهي انه قامت انتفاضات من أجل العدل في سنوات تحمل ارقاما قرآنية،
قامت انتفاضة فاطمية سنة 290 هجرية،
لأن 290  هو الرقم الغنوصي لفاطمة،
البنت المحببة للرسول وأم الحسين،
حسين الآخر الذي قتل في كربلاء،
وفي نفس الوقت مرتبط باسم ماري، مريم،
في الإسلام الشيعي مريم لا تُفصل عن فاطمة.
الام فاطمة هي الام مريم.
سنة سنة 1922 اي بعد 1000 عام من صلب الحلاج في بغداد،
سوف يقدم  لوي ماسينيون رسالة دكتوراه حول آلام الحلاج،
ليعيد إلينا جزءا هام من ذاكرتنا،
وطيلة ما يزيد على أربعين عاما،
سوف لن نجد في البدلة الإفرنجية لماسينيون الا الحلاج.
يذكر عبد الرحمان بدوي في كتابه "شخصيات قلقة في الإسلام"،
ان آخر ما نطق به لوي ماسينيون المسيحي الكاثوليكي،
وهو على فراش الموت هو هذه الآيات القرآنية؛
"قل إني لن يجيرني من الله أحد"، الجن 22.
و" يَسْتَعْجِلُ بِهَا الَّذِينَ لَا يُؤْمِنُونَ بِهَا وَالَّذِينَ آمَنُوا مُشْفِقُونَ مِنْهَا وَيَعْلَمُونَ أَنَّهَا الْحَقُّ، الشورى 42.
وهذه الآيات هي آخر ما جرى على لسان صاحبه،
الحسين بن المنصور الحلاج عند صلبه قبل أكثر من 1000 عام.
اتوقف عند هذا الحد،
لأعود إليكم في الحلقة القادمة،
لأتحدث عن مأساة الحسين بن منصور الحلاج،
من خلال كتاب آلام الحلاج للوي ماسينيون.
أشكركم على المتابعة،
وإلى اللقاء في الحلقة القادمة،
على قناة أنا أفكر إذن أنا موجود...